To understand the importance of events
in Russia this weekend.
We have to turn the clock back
a bit to 2014.
When the Wagner group
was first identified
fighting to seize Crimea from Ukraine.
At the time
it was thought to have about 5000 troops
fighting mostly in Africa
and the Middle East.
Fast forward now to January
when the Ukraine and Ukraine,
the UK Ministry of Defense
put its numbers
at 50,000 fighters in Ukraine alone.
Those troops, most were recruited from
Russian prisons
played a crucial role in the war,
particularly in places
like Parma in the east,
where some of the bloodiest and longest
battles of the war took place.
With me here
now is former
US Director of National Intelligence
James Clapper.
Years of experience, decades,
I should say, looking into Russia
and what's happening there.
Thanks so much for joining us. Jim.
So first on Putin's leadership, is Putin
does he emerge from here
irreparably damaged?
Well, he's clearly damaged I think
irreparably remains to be seen.
I think we're
perhaps rushing
to judgment here
about the end of Vladimir Putin.
And I don't
I think it's a little early to do that.
But clearly, his stature, his prestige,
his image is diminished
both internationally and in domestically,
which is
one of the reasons
why I don't think he's going
to let Ghosn run around free and easy.
What is the fate of the Wagner Group,
which has enormous military influence
and its role in Ukraine
central, its role in Syria,
the war in Syria, central,
its role in several
little wars in Africa
that Russia has interests in Central.
But also Prigozhin,
with his own power center
in Saudi inside Russia are Prigozhin
and the Wagner Group
now themselves irreparably damaged?
Well, that remains to be seen.
And as a group, a critical question is
what is the fate of the Wagner group?
And as you indicated, in Ukraine,
they're the most effective fighting force
that the Russians have had.
And they're very active.
And from the Russian standpoint,
very effective and lots of other areas
that you enumerated.
So that's a great question.
What is going to happen to them?
They are ostensibly under the loose
egis of the GRU
Military Intelligence Organization,
which also controls the Spetsnaz,
their special operations forces.
So there is
somewhat of a functional kinship there.
And whether the Russian government
would attempt
to have a more more control
over the volunteer group
and its activities by tethering it
to some element
of the government, ministry of defense
or whatever remains to be seen.
But it's clearly
this is a big problem for the Russians
because of its effectiveness.
No question.
So the
public story is that Prigozhin peacefully
ended his advance towards Moscow,
has taken a deal to go to Belarus,
and some of his forces
are going to sign up with regular
Russian army units
and promotion's going to live safely
in Belarus.
Do you buy that deal?
Well, Jim,
maybe I spent too much time
in intelligence with this whole thing.
This deal to me is kind of fishy
that all of a sudden goes and stopped.
Turn left or turn back.
And then he's going to go to agreed
to go all of all places, Belarus,
which is essentially
from a security standpoint
or an extension of Russia.
I just I just wonder whether
it was a deal or somehow
behind the scenes, Putin exerted some
some form of leverage over Burgos and
that caused him to fall.
This is an
unanswered question,
obviously, and hopefully, as as
we learn more, we'll find out
just what happened.
But on its face, it's all fishy to me.
For a moment this weekend,
I know that Western intelligence
was looking at this.
And speaking of open
military confrontation
in Russia, there are still militias.
There's still a Wagner militia.
There's still other militias,
other potential challengers
to Putin's leadership,
or at least
it's the factional fighting there.
Does the U.S., does
the West have to prepare for
at least
the possibility
of Russia becoming a failed state?
Well, absolutely.
I mean,
and there are those out there,
the Russia watchers, who
already are saying
this could easily
be the beginning
of the end of the Russian Federation.
I personally think that, again,
it's a little premature, but it could be.
And as far as the U.S.
government
needs to be prepared for all those
all those options
above at all, though, from,
let's say this from
an intelligence standpoint,
anytime you have a nuclear power
in a situation
like this, you get real sense of
about the status of their nuclear forces.
So that'll be
on board
your uppermost in the minds of you
intelligence community.
Was there at any point,
do you think this weekend
the threat
that Russia's
nuclear weapons were at risk?
No. No, I didn't.
I didn't.
And I felt that way from
ever since the invasion
that while despite the threats
that obviously
the probability
of the use of nuclear weapons is
is not zero, but it's still pretty low.
And I don't think this situation
changed that their U.S.
intelligence folks
have told me for some time
that if Putin were to lose power,
he's far more likely to face a threat
from his right flank
than from any sort of progressive,
you know, inside the country.
If he were to leave power
Who what kind of person is yourself from?
What category
would be most likely to replace him?
Would it be
someone more aggressive, more?
Well, I would
I think it would
it would all depend
on the circumstances of his departure.
If he were to do the part of all.
You know, he does
have a close inner circle,
which is held together pretty well.
I've always wondered
about his national security
adviser or equivalent Petruchio
as whether he might emerge,
but a long time crony KGB
crony of Putin's
So but I agree,
I think with you that the
the of the two theories
on attack
of some sort from the right
is more likely then than the left.
Final question,
if I can, in terms of the effect
on the ongoing war in Ukraine,
if you were advising Ukrainian leaders
now, military
commanders, would you say
now's the time to strike even harder?
Well, actually, not.
I think I'd probably tell
if I were in that position
of the Ukrainian military
to just press on with what
they're already
they've already gone under way
and let the disarray take,
you know, take its course
among the Russians.
The thing you want to
think about
is if you get very aggressive right now,
will that provoke a a counter
retaliatory retaliation
that we might not want to see?
So I think they just need to know
what they're doing.
And I think the demoralization
and the incompetence of the Russian
military is probably going
to be emphasized
even more because of this.
This event,
more questions about their will to fight.
Director James Clapper,
thanks so much for joining us, Jim.